today's video is kindly sponsored by
surf
shark find out more later in the video
hey
42 here high up in the andes where
bolivia
and peru meet lies the sparkling waters
of late titty car car oh grow up
at 3 800 meters above sea level
it's the world's highest navigable lake
that is it's the highest lake you can
drive a large boat through
and at 280 meters deep
118 miles long and 50 miles wide
it's the largest body of fresh water in
south america
it's so big that landlocked bolivia
has a naval station here surrounded by
snow-capped andean peaks
perilously hilly towns and peacefully
sleepy villages
lake titicaca is an unquestionably
splendid site but neither its
breathtaking beauty
nor its awesome size are the most
remarkable thing
that lake titicaca has to offer
for this mountain paradise is home to
the mysterious
auros people who live on the very
lake itself floating on man-made islands
constructed
entirely of reeds made completely by
hand by their inhabitants
these islands have been here for
hundreds of years
whilst the inca empire rose and fell to
the spanish conquistadors
while cities were built wars were fought
the auros have stayed living very much
the same life
as they have for centuries out
on the glittering surface of late
titicaca
if you take the long voyage to visit
lake titicaca
you should use the fastest and easiest
vpn
surf shock to make sure you're not
locked out of all your accounts from
back home
such as your bank and did you know surf
shark
also helps you to avoid price
discrimination based on your location
so you can actually save money on plane
tickets and car rentals
whilst traveling surf shark runs on any
device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and
dns leak protection and 24 7
customer support by using surfsharkvpn
you can stay anonymous and secure online
personally i use surfshark to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk
it's so easy all you have to do is
switch over your location settings
and there you have it access to all your
favorite programs
surfshark maintains a strict no logs
policy
and their network of 3 200 servers
in over 65 countries runs completely on
ram so they couldn't even like your data
even if they wanted to
by using the code 42 you will benefit
from an
83 percent discount plus free extra
months
for free all you have to do is click the
special link in the description
below don't miss out but
how on earth did the auros people get
there in the first place
living on a lake surrounded by
snow-capped peaks
might sound idyllic but building your
own island
also seems like pretty hard work it's
not the kind of thing
anyone does just for fun if i went to
daenerys lake and tried to build
a floating home i'd end up with little
more than
soggy underpants and if i did somehow
manage it
i probably wouldn't want my family to
live such a
solitary and arduous life out on the
lake
for 500 years yet
that's exactly what the auros people did
no one really knows for certain how or
why
the auros people came to live on the
lake but
the best guess is that an ancient
corporate team building event
got really out of hand well
either that or the auras people were
running from persecution
by the fierce armies of the inca
and quite possibly from others before
them
it's thought that the auros originally
lived in the amazon jungle
but facing enemy attack they ran
until they found themselves on the
shores of lake titicaca
with nowhere to go but into the water
they paddled out into the lake on
whatever boats they could make or find
and created a new home using nothing but
reeds and bare hands suddenly they went
from life in the depths of the jungle
to a home on a mountain lake that's
quite different from simply
relocating to the suburbs and spending
your days comparing lawn mowers
with your neighbor barry the accountant
it would have taken something pretty
fierce to force an
entire tribe out of the bountiful jungle
and onto the sparse surface of the lake
and that something was the anchor
the inca were once just a small mountain
tribe themselves
but then they got pretty serious about
it all and grew an
empire that stretched from colombia to
chile
with 10 million inhabitants at its peak
they built incredible cities most
memorably machu picchu
and 26 000 miles of roads
and they did all of that without any
written language
so far as we know and with no wheel
and no horses and since their empire
only lasted 100 years
until it was ended by the invading
spanish it's fair to say
they were pretty busy people it's also
fair to say
that no one gets to conquer hundreds of
tribes
and build an empire that consumes half a
continent
without being a tad bloodthirsty
they were fearsome opponents on the
battlefield
approaching in formation and in silence
before launching coordinated attacks
using arrows
and other gruesome weapons when the
spanish arrived
the inca struggled to match them but
they still put up a pretty good fight
filling covered holes in the jungle full
of sharpened stakes
and luring their enemy onto them to be
impaled
they also famously sacrificed their
children
16th century spanish immigrants to peru
juan de botanzas
described this barbaric practice these
children would be collected from all
over the land
and would be carried in litters together
they should be very well dressed
paired up female and male
it's thought that once collected the
children were kept in captivity for
several months
where they were fed coca leaves and
alcohol before being trekked up a
mountain
and sacrificed to the gods
it's a fair bet that the auros were
pretty frightened by the inca
but mighty as they were the inca were
not able to hold back the spanish tide
and their empire ultimately fell to a
combination
of the spanish army's advanced weaponry
and imported smallpox
and it would be nice to think that the
auros safe on their islands felt pretty
smug
when the conquistadors rocked up in town
their position of safety on the lake
meant they were protected from the worst
of the spanish onslaught
the auros islands were built with
defence in mind
many of the islands had watch towers one
is still active to this day
made of reeds of course from where the
auros would gaze out over the lake
to keep an eye out for marauding inca or
spanish troops
and the auros's trump card under attack
they could simply cut their moorings and
allow their islands to
float off to a safer more remote part of
the lake
ultimately neither the inca nor spanish
bothered the auros much
both viewed them with contempt but
neither saw them as a threat
worth fighting after all the only lands
they were defending
wasn't even technically land
so that explains how the auros people
ended up on the lake
but how did they manage to build islands
out of nothing but reeds
and not only islands but houses
schools shops and boats
well making a reed island is mostly a
matter of timing
the tough thick roots of the tatora reed
which grows all over the lake are used
for the base
and these naturally float to the surface
during the november to march rainy
season
the base of each island is around 2
meters thick
and only the best routes can be used to
make it
they must be clean and free of soil
which could drag a newly built island
down into the water
collecting the best routes each season
has become somewhat of a competition
amongst islanders
on top of the base of roots reeds are
laid
and laid again layer upon layer upon
layer of reeds is needed to make an
island stable and habitable
the islands are then kept in position
with ropes
and very long eucalyptus stakes that are
driven into the lake bed
considering that lake titicaca has an
average depth of over a hundred meters
it must be a bit of a search to find
somewhere to moor an
island but the auros are nothing
if not resourceful naturally a reed
island
doesn't last forever each has to be
constantly maintained
with extra layers of reeds added every
few weeks
to keep the auros's feet dry and their
homes
cosy an island will last for about 30
years
being maintained in this way before it
must be dismantled
and completely rebuilt there are
somewhere between
60 and 100 islands on the lake housing
around
1 200 people most islands
are tiny around 15 meters square
and home to just a few families living
in tiny reed houses
if an island starts to break up or
perhaps its residents just
fancy a change they might combine with
another island
providing the auros a constantly
changing landscape
as yet no one knows if they sometimes
decide to chop an island in half
following a family disagreement
and whilst the waters of lake titicaca
are mostly calm
there's always the danger that a sudden
storm will cause devastation
in fact in 1986 many of the islands were
destroyed
by a particularly bad storm and
most had to be completely rebuilt
wisely the islanders chose to rebuild
much closer to the safety of the shore
than they were before but what is life
actually like for the islanders
for hundreds of years they've lived a
peaceful existence
fishing in the lake and hunting birds
some
keep rabbits and guinea pigs a famous
delicacy of the region
though a very bony one you'll actually
see
guinea pig and chips on restaurant menus
throughout peru
unsurprisingly you won't see many cows
or
goats on the islands but some families
rear them
on the shore presumably to give
themselves an occasional break
from roast guinea pig they also eat
the very reeds they use to make their
homes
the bottom part of the reed contains
iodine which is eaten for its medicinal
properties
reeds are also used as bandages and
topical painkillers
so if a auros child hurts her knee
rather than a plaster
she'll have a reed wrapped around her
leg reeds are also said to have cooling
properties so the islanders use them to
cure headaches
hangovers or simply to cool down
they even make reed tea though we've got
no idea what that actually tastes like
perhaps it would be nice with a
digestive but
in many ways despite the fact they spend
their days on a
soft floating structure and every step
they take feels a bit like
walking on a sponge life on lake
titicaca
is surprisingly modern on the islands
you'll see tv aerials fixed to the reed
houses
along with solar panels the solar panels
have made island life considerably safer
for reasons you can imagine knocking
over a candle
on an island made entirely of reeds
isn't generally advised there's also
phone signal and internet and the
islands have their own radio station
auros children can go to nursery and
primary school
on the main island though the school run
might rank as one of the most dangerous
in the world
at least for the very youngest an
overcrowded boat collects
small children many of them too young to
swim
and takes them across the lake's
freezing waters to the school
without a lifejacket in sight i suppose
it beats being collected for ritual
sacrifice
by the inca older children have to take
themselves to school
on the mainland a journey of two
kilometers
paddling across the lake in a laundry
bucket
when they grow up many of these kids
will no doubt end up
using their education to live rather
different lives on the mainland
for those that stay the only game in
town
is tourism the big storm that destroyed
the islands in 1986
and forced a rebuild near the shore also
brought the islands into the
international spotlight
and ever since an increasing number of
visitors have come to experience
life on the lake the islands have become
a well-worn stop on the peruvian
backpacker trail
with 200 000 people visiting every year
most only stay for around 30 minutes
take some photos
buy a few read handicrafts and then
leave
though some stay overnight with local
families for the full island experience
many auros were initially dubious about
this tourist invasion
after all they'd lived largely
undisturbed lives
for hundreds of years hunting birds and
eating fish
but once it was clear there was money to
be made
those who hadn't yet moved their islands
close to the shore
immediately cut their moorings and
paddled their homes over towards the
tourist hordes
today 80 percent of the auros people
make
their living from tourism though they
take it in turns
each day half the islands open up to
tour boats
with the residents dressed up head to
toe in colorful traditional costumes
and presumably hide their somewhat
off-theme satellite dishes behind reeds
meanwhile on the other islands they
change back into
jeans and t-shirts and get on with
hunting fishing and watching the game on
tv
and the next day they swap over again it
must feel a bit like living in a human
zoo
and it's not a life all of the auros are
happy with
some chose to live on the islands
furthest from the shore
as far away from the day trippers as
they can possibly get
and of course all of the oros could
decide to simply
cut off the tourists and stop
entertaining visitors
they could pull up their moorings and
take their island off across the lake
but that would plunge them into a pretty
harsh existence
life on a reed island in the middle of a
lake
hundred meters above sea level when
nighttime temperatures are regularly
below freezing and the oxygen levels are
only 65 percent of those at sea level
is a bit of a ball lake to put it
lightly
even with the endless stream of
cash-laden visitors
the auros people remain poor
and without tourism it's likely that the
islands would no longer exist
at all without the tourist cash there
would be little to survive on
and no money for solar panels so
what's next for the auros selling
handicrafts to tourists brings in an
income
but it might not be enough to give the
auros a solid future
the children who paddle over the lake to
school in laundry baskets
might well decide that ireland life
isn't for them after all they no longer
have
the peaceful hunter-gatherer existence
they once had but they're unable to
fully embrace the modern world
either as their children start to move
away from the islands
it might just be that they end up more
of a museum
than a village and if that happens
it won't be a surprise but the world
will lose
one of its last links with the
incredible human determination
that took us to every untrodden corner
of the world
and into some of its harshest
environments
us humans are an endlessly resourceful
and hardy bunch and if nothing else
the auros people of lake titicaca
are a living testimony to that
thanks for watching